and I was eight years old I was
delivering papers door-to-door knocking
on doors expanding the paper out you
cannot win without hustling yeah costs
money right I guess what you got to do
you got to get money
rise and shine
it's n spresso time good morning believe
nation it's evan my one word is believe
and i believe in you i believe you have
an amazing gift inside you that i want
to see exploded onto the world so grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
hustle over to you jordan belfort i was
a born entrepreneur that's right exited
my mother's womb when i was 8 years old
i was delivering papers door-to-door
knocking on doors expanding the paper
route when i was 12 years old I was
shoveling driveways after snowstorms in
New York made twenty bucks a driveway
after a big snowstorm
I hit it big for the first time when I
was 16 selling Isis on the beach blanket
- blanket the blanket night but that's
how it started and after that I was
hiring people to come work at little I'd
twelve year old kids selling puka shell
necklaces for him and mother was
buttering bagels in the morning and that
was really the way I always was was you
know moving towards life yeah I was just
you know always wanted to make my hustle
does not guarantee your success but it's
your ticket to the show you cannot win
without hustling again it doesn't mean
that you will win just because you're
working hard but you will never win
without having the hustle and that
applies to every area of your life and
your business if you want to win an
entrepreneurship you have to work really
hard you have to work smart and you have
to work hard because if you don't you'll
get crushed by the people who are
working smart and hard if you want to
win as a husband or as a wife you have
to work hard in your relationship if you
want to win as a father or a mother you
have to be there for your child and work
hard on that relationship wherever you
are spending your time and really
dedicating yourself to that's the area
that is going to grow and so even
looking at whatever important projects
you have whatever you say your ambitions
are whatever you say your big
Bulls are does that map to what you're
actually doing look at your schedule
does your schedule does your daily
activities map to your ambition the
things that are you are doing on a daily
basis if you keep doing those things
will it lead to the goals that you have
for yourself and for a lot of people
they don't you're doing stuff and only a
small percentage of it actual eighths
that you accomplishing that big goal
that big dream of yours and so it's a
matter of shifting that perspective it's
a matter of changing your schedule so
that where you are working will lead to
you accomplishing your goals so you
start with the goals where you want to
go and then map it back to your weekly
calendar Monday to Friday or Saturday
Sunday for business for relationships
other stuff as well map everything out
your personal time your business time
does the activities in your calendar if
you keep doing those things every single
week will it lead to you accomplishing
those big goals that you have for
yourself I'm also big believer that when
you are working hard on your goals you
can pass people who've been doing this
for years or decades sometimes just
because you were putting in the hustle
where they aren't a quick example a
couple years into my speaking career I
connected with an agency in New York and
they didn't want to take me on these are
guys who deal with people from CNN and
big news networks and big thought
leaders and they helped turn those
people into into celebrities and the
thought leaders in to be able to have
products into getting their brand their
name out there and I thought this is
really cool like an agent for a thought
leader that's really cool I want to
explore this when I first time I call
with them they said you're not good
enough as a speaker for us to work with
you and that really hurt because hurt
had been speaking for a couple years but
compared to who they were working with I
wasn't good enough I didn't pass the
line and I didn't meet the minimum
standard but they loved my message of
belief they loved what I stood for this
is where when you figure out your one
word it can get you into doors because
people through your passion connection
even when you don't have the skills or
resources to be there it allows you to
play a bigger game even though you
shouldn't be there right and so they
loved my message of belief I said okay
we're gonna take a flier on you and so
my agent gave me my first assignment and
that was to tell my foundation story
he had me do it in the morning and I
would make this videos 30 40 minutes and
then send it to him he'd give me
feedback I'd make it again at lunch he'd
give me feedback and make it again in
the evening and so two to three times a
day every day I would make this video
and in that process I took his feedback
and I got better now this wasn't making
a 1-minute quick video was thirty
minutes each time was a lot of work to
put together but I was committed to
achieving that goal of being a better
speaker and with the guidance he gave me
I grew quickly and it must have made
that video 3040 times
overall before I had a final version
that he actually kind of liked I quickly
went from being the worst at the agency
almost not getting in not being a good
enough speaker to being one of the best
to being the one that they started
sharing my videos to say look at what
Evans doing you should be doing it like
he's doing it I became the best practice
case from being the worst in only a
couple months I went from the worst to
among the best in a couple months and
it's not because I have a natural skill
or gift or talent if you look back on my
old youtube videos you can see that I
was very nervous and very awkward and
the videos were terrible and it's just
because I worked hard because I was
making three videos a day to practice
and hone my skills where everybody else
that you can see had a hard time finding
time to do one video a week and so
somebody's doing three a day and
somebody else is doing one a week even
if this person is way ahead of them this
person's gonna catch up really quickly
and so you could take that same approach
in your business there may be people who
are way ahead of you who have decades of
experience sometimes but they've grown
slow they've grown lazy the world is
changing and you can quickly pick up on
the new trends and just by hustling
harder when they're doing one thing a
week you're doing it three times a day
you will catch up to them and you will
pass them at a lightning pace because
you were just hustling harder than they
are and so yes you have to work smart
and yes you have to be conscious of
where you're spending your time and you
have to hustle and you have to work hard
and that applies to your business that
applies to your life that applies to
relationships whether you're a husband
and wife father mother it applies to
every area of your life where you are
spending your time and dedicating
yourself to become excellent
that's when excellent things start to
happen now I have a special bonus clip
for you that I think you're really going
to enjoy but before getting to that my
question the day is what is the area in
your life for your business that you
really want to double down and hustle
harder at to become one of the best in
the world at leave it down the comments
below
I'm really curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love enjoy the bonus clip and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot event spresso
[Music]
I was from Harlem and I moved to my
Vernon when I was like 12 I didn't
really know anybody I knew that I wanted
to start thinking about what I was going
to do with my life and at 12 years old
yeah 12 yeah so you know I started
delivering papers and I had a paper
route and started delivering multiple
papers I wasn't supposed to have a paper
route but I made a deal with the you
know some of the paper boys in the
neighborhood that were going to college
let me deliver your papers and I seen
y'all half the money so they was with
that and that's the really hot I started
to get my hustle on and just like I ran
to get the tape I would make sure that I
put the paper inside the door so two
older ladies wouldn't have to come out
their house in the cold so it was always
about doing like the best and the
greatest job I could do living in Mount
Vernon there was just one Kingdom on
Vern it was one guy that made it out of
my earning and it was it was Heavy D and
so I had all my heroes and stuff from
Harlem when I moved to my learning and
then you know I saw my first rap star
and I could you know he lived in the
area you know I was so consumed with rap
and I was just so in love with it and
the heavy the heavy deed was just so fly
like in it he was a big guy he was
dancing and he was like he was like
almost like the flies that came out of
hip-hop
not just because he was a big guy flying
just straight flop and I'm saying from
his haircuts to the suits to Teddy Riley
combined it on being hip-hop so he was
just like a guy that I was like I gotta
meet this guy you know what I would wait
around the pizza shop that he would come
to I would just sit outside the pizza
shop on one day he came in the pizza
shop and you know I said to him you know
I want to talk to you about being your
manager like like I went all the way
without this is like when I was like 17
you know and so I'm like I'm gonna be
your manager you know I'm not really
knowing the game I'm not really can if
he had a manager I'm like you know a
number an opportunity I might as well go
for the gusto and he like kind of like
laughs that means like you crazy you
know I'm saying he bought me a slice of
pizza and I was telling him you know I
really want to be in the music industry
you know and you know I'm interning now
with WBLS that was the radio station but
I really really really want to get down
with you and uptown and then I said you
know you know maybe you could give me a
meeting with Andre Harrell and he was
just like yeah yeah that sounds good
sounds good he's just like you know you
were you a different type of guy like I
like your hustle and where you're coming
at me and he said let me see what I
could do how many months it take to do
that it took like maybe eight months of
like persistence I used two minute I
remember I went from stalking him at the
piece of shop to like it was like a fork
in the road to like where like he would
have the very off to the left to go to
his house but then it was re gonna kind
of a Main Street so I used to just walk
up and down that block the hope to see
his car to be like yeah yeah it was up
like I was on the block I had no problem
with playing myself
have no problem with any of that I just
had my I was on the prize
and I was excited to see him I was
excited to be chasing my dream to be
walking up and down the sidewalk you
know just making sure he didn't get
embarrassed a little bit in the time it
just perfectly and he drove past me like
three times I never caught him net but I
got I got enough heart one day I said
I'm just gonna walk up to his house like
I need this how bad I need this I'm
gonna walk up to his house and I was
like no you can't ring the doorbell and
then I was just I just made sure that I
would I would walk by his house and one
day he was outside and I said you know I
really need you to you know make this
call for me and then you know he you
know that he had the cell phone and I
guess you know it was kind of big and
everything and he pulled it out he made
the call and he set up he set up a man
for me to meet with you hmm
as a kid when you were starting out like
I know you know they had a lemonade
stand and did you start off having a
business as a kid I used to cut grass
man I just pushed my lawnmower around
the hood you know 10 11 years old
excellent old lady's gonna cut the grass
you know everyone from that took me
standing on the corner by the house but
I still was cool with you know that's a
man come out you know give me food
Sunday you know me I come eat with us go
back on the block I never told nobody
this is something that you'll be doing
Georgia like doing the summers kids we
used to go throw watermelons without our
elders I see still watermelons with my
uncle you get bit by snakes anything
butts grind these big-ass fields he
throw watermelons and whatever that load
is he might give you 20 $30 for that day
you've been in the Sun all day at the
end of the week I might have you know
100 dollars but a hundred dollars and
ones and what a 20 on top look like a
lot I see just fool all my friends like
you don't get money you know I mean it
was like damn Jeezy like how to [ __ ] the
early like we making the money you make
we didn't pay close but always been
that's a boss so I'm gonna go hard no
matter what cuz I gotta feed my family
and I gotta feed myself and I'm and if
you notice on my snap I'm trying to make
it super clear when I get something to
eat it costs money to eat great but you
got to pay the bill like if it's a
cheeseburger that's five hours it's five
hours every some flaming yarn it's 35
hours you know God forbid you want a
lobster this is food that's what and I
try to tell the young world I don't know
why they're not telling them yeah costs
money cheating right right guess what
you got to do you got to get my hat see
you know it makes me mad at people who
try to discourage people from getting
money like it's a problem I didn't
create the system right yeah if it was
free I would thank you you're saying and
then so what I'm trying to say is we
have to hustle we have to get money like
you know cheat teach the young world
work hard
strive hard it's okay I remember when I
was young I told me Khalid you you're
gonna get a Hyundai so I went and bought
a phantom no dude I'm saying like you're
so trying to tell you like that's not
saying if you want to wear dope sneaker
what's wrong Elena don't sneak it it
will cost money okay right great work
hard like what they don't want us to
wear dope sneakers they don't that's it
and that's the that's the major key they
don't want us to
so I'm then you know straight up they
don't want big boy to have the number
one morning show in the country yes a
black guess what we got the number one
show in the country if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you up or that would become
like a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details